so this is a score from the movie
sunshine directed by Danny Boyle
screenplay by Alex garland a film that
portrays a mission to reignite the Sun
the Sun is dying
and humanity's last hope is a ship
that's gonna deploy ten thousand nuclear
bombs to reignite the Sun of you what a
plot and the music the score perhaps
more than anything else is the soul of
the film for it manages to render an
ineffable feeling which is to come face
to face with God himself read all the
human stories all the religious myths
all the origin tales of the Son of God
so to speak well
referred to the son an ancient pagan
religions the son was God all of life
comes from it it is you know the the the
firt of the atoms that were cooked in
the furnaces of dying stars that created
everything it's open for human beings to
come face to face with that in the
observation deck in the movie sunshine
impregnates the plot with a metaphysical
and religious flavor and tone you can't
help but get caught up in larger
questions about what it means to be
sentient questions about the human
spirit
questions about our capacity to come
together and overcome the greatest
hurdles
[Music]
only dream I ever had is the surface of
the Sun this is one of the characters
has the incandescent lightbulb of
creation burns itself in their retina
metaphysical science fiction films blend
religion and science and psyche to
create a psychedelic experience that
cracks us open and lets in the light to
her stone to shovel horse and the divine
Dreamweavers that make these films that
compose these scores that direct these
screenplays the gods on the screen that
beckoned
the chores
what might be
we know what we are said Shakespeare we
know not who we might be
[Applause]
just sit with that for a moment ah
percussion kicks in intensity levels
rise emotion nears climax
[Music]
you spill over you overflow you mind
gasm
you went to God just to see and you were
looking at me
[Music]
the raptures radiates
[Applause]
seeing the songs that orchestrate the
universe
final
gasps
[Music]
speeches but a cracked kettle in which
we move while our psyches long to make
music that will melt the Stars